and both of these teams very willing and
capable of pushing in transition and
scoring quickly here's Clark working
around Fletcher Caitlin Clark has Iowa
on the board first Rick Box out from
Boston another chance here for Iowa
though sonano the speed and the Finish
Jackson has the position inside
surrounded and just taken away by sonato
Mark the get ahead right in the lap of
Warnock for two
37 of Caitlyn Clark's assists come and
transition that foul was on Saxton South
Carolina a Terry 15. Clark looking to
turn the corner lays it in through the
contact for Caitlyn Clark playing off
some players contesting others Caitlin
Clark has not seen that kind of Defense
all year long in terms of the power of
Olivia Boston but able to get by and
finish
Zaya cook off to a terrific start here
in the semifinals
Clark will fire and hit from three
South Carolina trying to deny Caitlyn
Clark much easier said than done here's
what it hurts deep three and because of
their Big's ability to switch on the
perimeter defense they don't Staley can
go with this giant lineup inside Laura
turns the corner and lays it in
nine points for Caitlyn Clark she's done
the work and Zaya cook has been the
mentally strong player here in the first
quarter
Clark great look senato lays it in
orchestrate make beautiful passes that
lead to easy but Iowa take advantage
remember South Carolina unlike most
teams that make it this far are
extraordinarily deep sanano lays it in
on the delivery from Clark
logo threes it is her ability to
facilitate to find open and unlike
Boston Clark is going to remain on the
floor cloak fading and hitting
Sydney a falter gets it in the arms of
Clark
Clark gets it across the timeline a deep
three is good
you try to deny a Caitlin Park the
basketball because with it in her hands
her range is almost Limitless this is
good defense by Raven Johnson
Caitlin Clark
dumps it to sonado on the roll serves it
in
outstanding crew including Carolyn Peck
honored at halftime headed to the
Women's Basketball Hall of Fame so will
she someday Caitlin Clark buries the
three
first three of the game for South
Carolina Stokke running on the other end
lays it in on the dime from Clark get
ahead passes and so many this season
from Caitlin Clark had landed in the
arms of Hannah Stokke bark has two fouls
herself as Marshall comes back for the
Steal
here is Clark
Sparks spinning into the paint gets to
the cup and reverses it in just cannot
grab a defensive rebound Caitlyn Clark
just going around here a Fletcher the
tough finish Boston spins flips can't
finish rebound into the arms of Marshall
here is Clark
Clark goes around Fletcher the leaner is
good delivering tonight Caitlin Clark
continues to Shimmer 23.7 assists
Clark into the paint stops dishes
Warnock put it
for three the overpowering size and
strength of South Carolina at every
position four
has the mismatch all Caitlyn forth now
you see her now you don't the big and
feet on the other Caitlin Clark knows
she's got six seven right there what do
I do
step right through
masterful once again a great give and go
between your big six seven Cardone so
easily passing it over to 6'5 Boston
Clark gets a clean look and knocks it
down
Clark eyes up using the screen from
sonato bounces to her on the roll for
two
here's Clark
a deep one you back
with 31 points you know she loves the
right to left crossover we've seen
multiple times in this game The Defender
right there and it still results in
three
Clark burning by Bill Caitlin four plays
it in
[Applause]
Clark curling around
Clark trying to work around Beale she
does Caitlyn Clark has 35.